hello my name is matt britton
and i'm the laboratory director for a
one bond laboratory
which is a subsidiary of sca limited and
we're a fairly new
established uh cannabis lab
in the state of ohio we're also doing
analysis
on hemp and cbd products
so today i'd just like to talk to you a
little bit about some of the
challenges that we kind of went through
in getting
our laboratory up and off the ground we
have quite a bit of experience
in analytical chemistry but in setting
up this lab
there are some unique challenges to just
in general
transitioning to more of a a fully
functional
and full one-stop kind of shop
laboratory so today i'll talk a little
bit about
method development some of the important
parts of
sample traceability and just data
management in general
so the objective of this talk is kind of
two-fold
one what we just kind of i gave you the
overview on
the analytical laboratory setup part and
then some of the
buzzwords and some of the pitfalls in
this whole
laboratory setup process
so the four main
objectives within the laboratory setup
is looking at your instrumentation
and the method development then also
sample flow as samples come in
how you track them and then that big
word traceability
and then once you have your samples and
you you run your analysis
there's the the data portion data
management and then also reporting out
to
your clients and then the very important
part of all analytical labs
is your quality assurance and
proficiencies
so instrumentation we'll start off there
the main
questions that you want to ask whenever
you're looking at
setting up an analytical lab is what is
the purpose of your lab
are you a regulatory lab so you're
following very specific requirements
that are handed down
through a government body or something
for
your particular client so you know what
your standard tests are do you know what
particular um requirements
are there if you're looking at
cannabinoids which what cannabinoids
you're looking at heavy metals what are
those heavy metals you you have specific
lists that are required
and there's also a second portion of a
laboratory and that's kind of like your
services
are you doing anything above and beyond
those uh
regulatory requirements or do you have
specific testing that
that is not a requirement and that would
be something that you're trying to
meet the needs of a customer that would
be like terpenes
or uh other types of analysis that
that would give your client more
information sometimes from
their point a marketing standpoint and
then other times would be
just something that they need to know
about their product um
to meet their profiles so
in looking at those lists of things that
and answering these questions that
you're looking for
what instruments do you need to fulfill
this purpose
is it um lc liquid chromatography gas
chromatography
do you need what is the uh your limits
of detection so how powerful do these
instruments need to be because you can
spend
a lot of money and a lot of time trying
to get
information trying to do things that are
not necessary
to meet your your purpose of your lab
and other times you don't want to be
finding instruments or getting an
instrumentation that
um is inferior and won't get you the
information that you want
so where where um
that uh up front costs and kind of have
those kinds of things in the back of
your mind then also as you're
pulling in laboratory equipment and
instrumentation try to think about other
technologies and how you're going to
integrate everything to speak
to um your systems as a whole
and then the final component if you're
setting up a lab from scratch
that's new you want to think about
what kind of goals long-term goals you
have for your laboratory so the
instrumentation what is their capability
not only
on um the tests and analytical methods
that they can do
but how quickly samples can be pushed
through
and you may spend a little bit more
up front to have some uh
rapid capabilities or some expandability
um versus buying something that would be
inferior to your long-term goals
so you have to kind of weigh those those
as a
different components to say if it's you
spend a little bit more up front so that
you have a little bit better
capabilities but you don't want to spend
something
so much up front you're buying something
that you'll never actually get to use
so once you kind of have the idea of
where your goal
is as far as what your laboratory is
going to be looking at
then you get into the method development
portion
this is really where your operators or
your chemists come into play
um it's really important to
seek out strong talent and talent that
has integrity so they know what they're
looking for
and they know how to use the particular
types of equipment that you're using
or to be able to know where the training
ability of these individuals are so can
they
can they pick up new instrumentation do
they have a broad scope
of methods um
particularly if they're a liquor
chromatography individual do they also
have some background in gc or would they
have
uh some ability to do microbiology so
look for
the individuals depending on how large
your lab is and what kind of
equipment that you need what their
capabilities are
and as i was saying uh the integrity of
the individual because
analytical techniques there's a lot of
ins and outs and a lot of ability to
um change or manipulate things and it's
really important to be able to trust and
be able to know that
the information that they are producing
is solid
so when you're going through this method
development process you really need to
sit back initially and look at your
feasibility do you have what you need
then um this is where probably the most
important part
is going out and doing your book
research
um i was once told that um
you can spend hours and hours and hours
in in the lab
uh trying to figure something out and it
can take you 10 minutes
of doing book research to get that same
answer
so it's important to be able to go out
look in literature
talk to your suppliers there's a ton of
information out there
on how to set up your methods what
columns to use
uh what some extraction techniques are
out there so you do your book research
and then you have your plan set in
motion and that's whenever you can
really start your development and get it
actually
set up on your equipment itself and then
once you have
that the base method in that's when you
go into the optimization stage and
that's where you're tweaking to really
tailor
your your brand really tailor your
instrument in your lab
to this method and to the clients
that um you want to serve
so after you have a solid method and you
really kind of get
the method set up exactly how you want
to you go into this characterization and
invalidation process and i'm going to
talk about validation
a little bit more on the next slide but
this is where you're really trying to
characterize out
your method to show what you are doing
is exactly what you say you're doing and
then once you have everything up and
running
it's just implementation and this is
where you're getting samples in
and you're able to actually produce data
so method validation validation is
really in a nutshell
just setting up a a system
and documenting that you are able to
test
specifically what you're saying you're
testing for and that
you have a high degree of certainty um
that you're able to provide your clients
with what you're saying you are
actually providing them and that your
results are trustworthy
and that anybody can look at
your method and say you have
shown everything you need to know
um to just prove that your method is up
and running the way it's supposed to be
so a few of the things that you look at
is your limited detection
um and your limited quantification your
precision accuracy
how how robust is your method what is
your
your range um how how low you go to how
high you can see as far as the amounts
within your samples
so there's a lot of different components
within method validation that you'll
have to
really kind of keep in mind as you're
setting up a validation plan
and there's a lot of different resources
out there to be able to
really kind of get all the different
components together
it's really important to take time and
really kind of walk through this
validation
um plan slowly
and um keep notes
and document everything that you are
doing and all of the
uh the data um so you have it in one
spot to be able to
put together a package to really show
your method is
is up and running at a high quality
so once you kind of have your um
methods and your instrumentation and
everything up and running and everything
is
is validated you're ready to actually
start
the uh client-facing portion
of the analytical testing this is really
where it comes down to your sample
management
how do you get samples what is the
workflow within your lab
the all-important traceability and then
your reagents and your consumables and
how
those kind of interplay within all of
the levels
of your sample management so to do this
a lot of times you need technologies or
softwares to kind of help integrate
within your laboratory
a process to to make this smooth
and pretty seamless a lot of times you
use what's called
a limb system or a laboratory
information management program
or system and
so this is really kind of the the
heartbeat
of an analytical lab and this is where
a lot of times it is required by your
government bodies
if you are a regulatory lab
and limbs can be used for a lot of
different things within a lab and
different lens programs have a lot of
different sections or different
components that that can be used
and some of them are really really
strong and some of them are um
not as good so a good limb system you
really
are able to track your your sample from
your
intake all the way through uh to the end
and that's basically what traceability
is
and i'll talk a little bit more about
that and especially in the cannabis
industry traceability is a very
important component
because of all the regulatory uh issues
that could come
in but a limb system um it will help as
you bring a sample in you
log it into this system and then a lot
of them have a function
of workflow so that it can
notify certain individuals that a sample
is ready for them
and depending on how the size of your
lab if you have different individuals
that do a lot of different things
as far as you may have a group of
individuals that
like lab technicians that do extractions
and do sample preparations as far as
vials are concerned then you may not
have another
group of chemists that actually do
uh workers with the instrumentation
and uh collect your data and reporting
and then once they do data analysis then
it may trigger somebody else for
an approval process so that you can
actually
have somebody do a peer review and then
a final review before
um your your data actually flows out to
your clients and then a lot of other um
components of a limb system some of them
have billing and can actually make
invoices
some will be able to produce your
reports for you
and they really are able to integrate in
many different locations within the lab
it's important when you're looking at a
limb system that they integrate with
your instrumentation
so that there is no transposition or
you're not transposing data
um to put them within or dropping it
into the limb system
that that data is pulled directly from
the instruments so that there's no
errors and you're not having to go back
through
and just do a peer check of data entry
you're trying to reduce the amount
of locations for possible human error
because once you have systems set up you
can
validate these systems like the limb
system and how it integrates with your
um instrument so you can verify that
everything works
smoothly and then once um
that verification process is done then
you should be able to trust
that whatever is falling data that flows
into your limbs
from your instrument directly doesn't
have to be peer checked
um on a constant basis so there are
different components and different
systems that
um you should as a laboratory manager or
director
to look at and that way you can get
something that you're comfortable with
and you can meet the needs of your
particular lab
so again the word traceability comes
into play
something i do want to just touch base
on for a few minutes and traceability is
really
the whole cradle to grave concept you
get a sample in
uh your door and it is your
responsibility
you have to be able to show everything
about that sample and that is
every hand that touched it every um
milligram that uh
was used you need to be able to show
where it went
and that that particular ingredient or
not ingredient that particular part of
the sample
was destroyed properly or used up
and then also you want to be able to
track what consumables that
that you utilize primarily because if
something would happen
and there's a recall on a consumable or
something of that nature
and that consumable was used in your lab
you will be able to trace
back what um samples that particular
consumable
um was associated with and then if there
is an
issue with that that may cause some
issues in your data um you would be able
to flag that information
and then be able to talk with your
client and be able to decide what needs
to be done
but that whole concept of traceability
it's really for your protection
and the protection of your lab and
everybody in your lab so that
if questions or something becomes
missing or something is lost
sample wise you would be able to track
backtrack
and trace to see where that sample was
and what happened to it so traceability
is really important especially
in a highly regulated industry
such as cannabis and then also other
pharmaceutical
style analytics
so the next component that you really
want to look at
once you kind of go from method
development getting your lab up and
running
samples start coming in and you're
producing data
and that's where you get to your data
analysis and your data management
uh analytical labs produce a ton of data
um and being able to
track that data analyze it
and then also keep it in an organized
manner is really important
for an analytical laboratory
so i think the biggest thing to look at
is to utilize the programs that you have
it's like the limbs program for instance
your data is flowing into that you use
that to produce reports and that
a lot of the the lens programs have a
data management
part or component of them so that allows
you to
store data and be able to retrieve it um
on a per client basis uh so you can keep
it all together
with each individual client so it's easy
to find and easy to work with
and then also it can be per different
types of tests
or instrumentation there's a lot of
different ways that you can organize it
you just have to organize it the best
way
for um for you and for what your
your lab is trying to do but
a big thing on your data analysis is
really trying to make sure that your
experimental controls
and that your data verification steps
are built in
to your data analysis and your
experimental controls are checking
that your instrument is running the way
it's supposed to and it falls within
that that validation package that you
develop that you
established so that the instrument's
running properly
and that you have um
a complete extraction so the actual
extraction techniques and those kinds of
things kind of fall within
the preview of this particular sample
and that you can trust the data that you
are producing
also within your data analysis and your
data management is kind of your check
and balance system
so an individual that produces data
there needs to be a secondary individual
like a peer review process
and then usually a tertiary review
and that would be by a senior analyst or
the laboratory director and that's your
final approval process before
a report is issued to a client
and those requirements are sometimes set
up either by the client themselves
or by the regulatory body that you are
trying to produce data for
so i know some states require that the
laboratory director is their final check
some require just a senior level
uh analyst so you have to understand
what your
the needs for your particular program
are and then
also how long data has to be maintained
and what the
condition of that data has to be in if
digital is
appropriate or if there needs to be any
type of hard copy of that stuff produced
so once you get all your data and
everything
is in a form that you're ready to
um present it to your client this is
where you get to that
the the reporting portion and
the heart of your lab
is the report itself that is what you
are producing you are not producing
numbers you're not producing
um a widget you are producing a report
and your report
is essential that you
can stand behind what your
what uh numbers you are producing that
it becomes defensible
because everything that you have is
validated and you have a
quality assurance plan or quality
management system
so you have your checks and balances
built in not just
to eliminate or eliminate uh human error
but also that you know your instruments
and your calibrations are always within
check
and that you would be able to to stand
behind
uh your data and this is really the the
data integrity process
and it's vital for our industry because
without it
um everything comes into question and
then everything can start falling apart
if people can start poking holes within
our methods
and how we do it so defensibility
and data integrity is paramount
for for our industry for not just the
cannabis industry but just the
analytical
uh chemistry as a whole
so those are really your big uh
components
for um setting up your lab
and in the the individual components
within
um your laboratory setup
once you kind of get through that
portion there's a few other kind of what
i like to call buzzwords or pitfalls
that
that you hear and that are expected uh
during this uh your client facing
and some of those big things are your
turnaround time
uh which really deals with uh client
satisfaction and how fast you get things
out there's a lot of
work that has to go into your
instrumentation and the records
um iso accreditation uh that's something
that
i'm sure uh comes up on every
conversation we'll talk
touch base on that and then just your
overall
general laboratory safety
so turnaround time so turnaround time
everybody
can do pretty much anything and
as far as uh your analytics are
concerned and just producing data
and those kinds of things but it's
always trying to find that balance
between
doing quality work how quickly you can
get to somebody and the cost
um those are kind of three big pillars
and
they always say i can do something um of
high quality
it may take a while and it can be cost
effective but if you want high quality
and you want it fast it becomes very
expensive so you try to
to put a balance in between these three
components
and all of that really goes into um
making your clients happy the client
satisfaction portion
and the biggest upfront problem
is just really managing those
expectations and and giving yourself the
time that you need to produce quality
data
but also make sure that you are
staying on top of things otherwise you
can get
um things can fall behind and components
can be missed so
it's really important to to be up front
and work with your clients if something
starts to
become in question and really just trust
the process
i mean you are developing um a high
quality lab that has
a good workflow process and the idea
is that you're taking that process and
you're using that
to get information to your clients
quickly
and some of the things that you can do
to help improve that is just really
leverage your technologies
lens programs and document management
systems there are a lot of different
types of softwares
out there that that are hugely important
and
they have a lot of power to help
if you utilize them properly and really
understand uh some of the different
components and
we talked a little bit about a limb
system and i'll talk a little bit more
about let's say a document management
system
sometimes it can be one in the same but
a lot of times
um they're not that there may be two
separate systems
and then also the other big thing is
utilize your instrumentation software
i've
looked at a lot of different labs and
have talked to a lot of individuals
and they are not utilizing
their instrument to their fullest
potential they're they're really trying
to do a lot of manual work
and a lot of uh different
things in stepping outside of what the
instrument can be doing for
them and they spend hours and hours
doing peer review or looking line by
line
when an instrument and the computer
program can do it in just a matter of
seconds or minutes so it's really
important to
look at the technology and to look at
the softwares that you have and the
availability of them
and look at their capabilities so that
you are utilizing them
to your advantage and then sometimes
also it's important to periodically look
at your
sops to make sure everything's
streamlined
because i know as time goes on
you may develop a process or something
new that
um and they just keep building and if
you really
step back and you look at your processes
and your sops
your standard operating procedures you
can like really question like well
is that necessary are we doing it the
most efficient way
and sometimes having an outside audit an
efficiency audit
is a good way to do that if you can
there's some outside
firms or a a sister
lab that you may know um
bring somebody else in from the outside
and let them see hey what are you doing
what are your processes and let them
start
asking questions in and really try to
push you to be more efficient and
sometimes that efficiency can reduce
your turnaround time
and sometimes that efficiency can really
be able to increase your workload
so there's a lot of different things
that um can be
a big advantage of being able to to do
that periodic check
to make sure that you are pushing or
doing the the proper
process this is within your lab
so also uh to make sure that you're
maintaining a strong lab
is your instrumentation records uh
that's kind of a big thing especially
in your career um accreditations
and the the big thing is you walk into
every lab it's like oh yeah no we do
x y and z we make sure that every
monday we're checking this part of the
instrument
or we're running this cleaning process
if it is not recorded
it didn't happen at least according to
um any type of regulatory body or
agency um and it should be the same way
for for you as a laboratory director or
laboratory manager if you can't look in
a notebook
um or within the lens system that does
any type of
uh recording for your instrumentation if
it's not there
it didn't happen even if the your
chemists
swear up and down that yes i do this
religiously every other day
they need to be recorded because it's
important that we do
our our daily and weekly maintenances
and then also our larger
preventative maintenance schedules to
keep the instruments running the way
they're supposed to be running
and also that can reduce your cost
of instrument repairs in long term
because your instrument that that's
that's the lifeline
of an analytical lab when they're down
when they're broke
uh when things are not working the way
they're supposed to be doing
you're not able to produce data you're
not able to produce reports
and then that's your clients are not uh
being serviced
so it's important to be able to look at
your maintenance logs and then look at
um that they're they're being serviced
in a proper manner
and also another way to another
important process
to look at um not just your maintenance
logs but also be looking at your
repair costs and be able to maintain
records of that so that you can start
looking at are the
this particular instrument or these
particular processes
starting to cost um quite a bit of uh
money in repairs
that way you know is it time
to look at upgrading an instrument or
replacing an instrument
and you can actually have documentation
to help to make those determinations
uh your limb system and some document
management systems actually have
um modules for
instrument uh information which you
should be able to utilize
and to be able to help maintain those
records and then also if
you are asked from clients or iso
or any type of accreditating body you'll
be able to produce those records without
any problems you're not actually trying
to
to find receipts or those kinds of
things because you can actually have
them
it's all stored in one location which is
really helpful
so the next topic on these buzzwords and
pitfalls that i'd like to just
briefly touch on is iso accreditation
everybody is looking for lab
accreditations there's several different
bodies but iso is one of the
the larger ones that especially most
your regulatory labs
um are are required to have
and iso is really just looking at your
procedures and your processes and that
you are
maintaining your instruments and that
you have your validation packages
are are proper and there everything's
within is in order
and it's just document document document
they're looking at
your quality they're looking at how you
work with your customers they're looking
at complaints they look at
are you um looking towards
the future as far as making sure that
you can
have any improvements of your process or
you look at risks
how do you handle samples there's a lot
of different things that go within
um looking at or from an accreditation
standpoint
and they're this is a process that takes
quite a bit of time to do
but in the end it is um
extremely important to make sure that
you can
have your methods accredited and that
you are able to produce
a credible and reliable information for
your clients
and it's important to be able to um
maintain
um a strong accreditation um in this
process
there's individuals that are out there
to be able to help um
and it's just a matter of walking
through uh the step-by-step procedures
um to maintain your accreditations and
then have your
your um bi-annual audits and those kinds
of things
to to help maintain this accreditations
and then the last thing i want uh to
look at is just your laboratory safety
and your personnel
uh training records your personal
training records is part of
um your audit uh trail
and also your iso accreditation so it's
important to be able to
know that you have been training your
employees properly
not only for yourself but also for their
safety and for
their their proficiency at what their
what
they claim or say that they're able to
do as far as
uh the types of experimentation that
they are able to
do in the lab what kind of extraction
techniques
and that that you're just maintaining a
safe environment
so train records are really important
and then also being able to maintain
a list of any type of lab injuries or
what we would call near misses if
something
almost happened that way you can be
looking for trends
and to really understand is there ways
that you can become more efficient
or things that you can do as far as to
help reduce
any type of uh potential injuries
or any potential accidents
because they're again not just very
similar to
with instruments break or something
becomes offline if an individual
one of your chemists or your lab
technician is injured or becomes ill
because of something within the lab
you're not only
um hurting that individual or that
individual has
some problems but as a lab as a whole
you're not because you're not as
efficient because you're missing a fully
trained
uh person uh within the lab some of your
personnel
so other parts of laboratory safety to
look at
is is what kind of chemicals and what do
you have within the lab what chemicals
are present
and then also knowing where they're
located and this is important
if there would be an accident or a fire
of something of that nature that you
would know what is there
where it's at so that you can be able to
address any concerns
uh in those in that area then also
knowing your chemicals is because
you have to have access to your data
safety sheets
um and those are things that give all
the important information about the
chemicals within the lab and that's
required for
um you to have that information for your
uh your chemists or your technicians or
anybody that comes within the lab they
should be able to find that information
rapidly
and be able to review it and should have
reviewed it before they start handling
any type of chemicals
there are a couple of programs out there
that help you
manage these safety data sheets
or it can be something that's uh
maintained manually
but you have to also make sure if you
are maintaining them manually
that you are keeping them current so
that
if you have acetone or something that's
in the um
laboratory con or all the time that you
are
maintaining the most update version of
those
sds the safety data sheets because they
do change periodically and some
change um between different vendors so
if you would have
vendor a and then you decide to switch
to vendor b because they don't have it
available or cost
sometimes those data safety sheets can
vary
and it's really important to be able to
make sure and maintain
the most update and that they are as i
said accessible to
um your employees
so i really appreciate your time today
and then i hope that
some of the information that you gather
from this i know it was a high level
overview just to kind of give you an
idea
of some of the components that go into
setting up an analytical lab
particularly in the cannabis or
cbd arena and it's
been my pleasure if you have any
questions please feel free to reach out
to
me and i would be able to
try to get you connected or be able to
answer whatever i can
i appreciate it thank you